be a person's First fiction,
whatever is is theirs. The
prophet would honor that
invitation exactly as the
invitation was given to him.
Meaning that if he came and
there was someone with him that
was unexpected by the host, he
would ask the host permission
for the person to proceed with
them. and he would say this
individual came with us If you
wish to allow him
to allow him along with us as a
guest Otherwise, he will, he
will return. belief. Now, it's
important for us to understand
something. When it comes to
permission There are two types
of permission with the of Islam
In Dhaka, Edun,
[Silence]
and then there is permission
which is specific.
If a person understands
permission
then they
may act upon that
understanding So, for instance,
if a person is invited to a a
home of one of their close
friends or relatives, somebody
they know is they're very close
with. And they understand that
this person would not have a
problem if I brought another
person with me. Even if they
don't know that person. My
guest is their guest, right?
And this is considered to be
permission. I don't have to
specifically ask him for
permission for that. Because
the permission is understood.
However, if a person, if a
person is uncertain of that
permission, would this person
have a problem with this or
not, then the individual goes
back to the default position
and that is, you do not have
permission until explicitly
given. and this permission need
and be permission which is
given reluctantly Person gives
reluctant permission. Or agrees
reluctantly. This is not
permissible and is not
considered permission. What we
say for instance to shame
someone into something. right?
So, I bring someone to another
person's house and I say, well,
if you want them to leave, they
can. You know, basically put
them in a situation where they
can't really keep face and make
a decision that is objective
based on what they want.
They've now been shamed into a
position. So, they're going to
say yes simply to say face.
This is not considered
permission. Even if the person
says, yes, I give them
permission. It doesn't mean
that. They've actually given
permission. Anytime a person
puts another person in a
position where they give
reluctant permission because
they've been shamed into
something then, this is not
considered, this is not
considered valid permission in
the original sense. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
about this type of permission
in the Quran. He tells us and
give women that you marry their
dowry. Beautifully.
and if they are truly
enthusiastic about forgiving
any portion of that dowry or
giving you back any portion of
that dowry, then that is their
decision and you can have
whatever they give you. So,
notice here how Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala mentions that. They
have to be enthusiastic about
that that giving. What is the
nature of a husband and wife
there, their marriage, right?
Their relationship especially
at the beginning of marriage
when dowry is traditionally
given.
what is, you know, what is most
common, is that a woman
generally, Bill
heed into the desires of her
husband even if she doesn't
necessarily agree. Even if
she's reluctant. She may faint,
agree, agreement, in order to
placate her husband. Cater to
his desires. So if a man as a
husband says to his wife,
please, you know, give me a
portion of your dowry or
forgive me of whatever I owe
you of your dowry If she knows
that he's going to be upset
with her or he's going to be
take it to heart or what have
you, she may say. Yeah, sure.
Even if she is very reluctant
and under normal circumstances
would not would not have chosen
that. This is not something
permissible for a person to
take under these circumstances.
when it comes to an employer
with his employee, right? They
are using, they have a position
that is not objective when it
comes to giving choices. So,
there's something a kind
of a proxy choice or a
fake choice that is presented
there. An illusion of choice.
You could choose this or you
could choose this. If you
choose A, I'm going to be upset
with you but I mean,
technically, you can, right?
The unspoken ramifications of
not catering to your superiors
desires. This is not considered
to be a choice. person who
chooses this has chosen it
under a a type of duress,
right? And so, this is not
permissible. Has meant it, has
mentioned this even to the
point of,
a husband inviting his
Christian or Jewish wife to
Islam. right? Does Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
the Quran?
There is no duress in choosing
one's religion. But if the
husband who is in the Quran a
figure that is a figure of
authority, tells his wife who
is a figure of
a subordinate Wouldn't you like
to become Muslim? It she may
accept Islam Simply for the
fact that she wishes to please
her husband rather than it
being an objective choice. Now
this obviously doesn't mean
that no husband should invite
his wife to Islam if she's not
Muslim. But Sheikh Allah and
others who have mentioned this
of the are calling attention to
this issue. The issue of a
person recognizing his position
of authority when offering a
choice to his subordinate. a
figure of authority offering a
choice to your subordinate, it
needs to be a real choice. to
be a real objective choice that
they can autonomously make
without the fear of
ramifications if offering them
a choice is what you choose to
do. And when it comes to their
rights conceding any part of
their rights, then this is
dually important. more
important because a person may
take another's rights without
right to do so, without them
being happy about it. Without
them, with with their extreme
reluctancy with a very heavy
heart and this is a type of
oppression. As the prophet has
mentioned. So, it is not
considered permission. If you
just show up at someone's house
with uninvited guests not
knowing or pretty sure that
they wouldn't be okay with this
or it's against the customs of
the people. In certain
countries or certain
communities, that maybe the
people's custom, that's fine.
But if it's outside of the
norm, usually when you invite
someone, you invite that person
specifically. And if that
person is to bring anyone else,
they should, ask for explicit
permission. If that is the
situation, then we need to make
sure that we offer a real
choice. Not just a an illusion
of choice. He says,
[Silence]
and another thing that the
prophet would do is that he
would have discussions while he
was eating. He would speak
Those around him and not you
know, specifically try to avoid
speaking.
and an instance of this is when
he said to his stepson
Teaching him how to eat
properly basically starts by
beginning with the name of
Allah and eat from that which
is immediately in front of you.
laminal man cool, walaminal
mangur. holiness,
[Silence]
vain. There are no statements
of the prophet regarding this.
Rather, there's no problem with
a person conveying a salaam to
people eating. There's no
problem with the person.
Speaking to someone who is
eating. There's no problem with
the person who is eating to
speak with someone else.
but shaking a person's hand
while they're eating. This is
not appropriate not
appropriate. Persons eating,
they may have washed their
hands before they begin to eat.
Lot of people feel
uncomfortable with this. I
personally feel uncomfortable
with this. Enough to just say
assalamu alaikum. And this also
takes us into an issue of every
time I see any person that I
know. Do I need to shake their
hand every single time I see
them? No.
Oh, I mean, there's some people
that you see every single day
or you see them three, four,
five, six, 10 times a day. This
it's not necessary to you know,
bridge the gap and shake each
other's hands vigorously.
There's twenty guys standing
there. I gotta go in a big
circle and shake every single
person's hand. This is not
necessary. Yes, it's the one
that shake your brother's hand.
but there is a time when it
could be too much and
overwhelming enough for a
person to say. Assalamu
alaikum. It's enough for a
person. If there's five, 10
guys standing there to just say
assalamu to them as a group.
It doesn't mean that it's a bad
thing for a person to of the
person's hand. Obviously,
that's not what I'm saying What
I'm saying is when this goes
too far and it becomes almost
you know, you can't go
into the masjid or leave the
masjid without shaking. 60
people's hands. This is not
particularly necessary. If this
is the custom of the people,
then, that's fine. But
especially when a person is
eating, this is an
inappropriate time to be
shaking one another's hands
[Silence]
He says, and another
you know, you want something to
drink Usually, there's an
exchange there of two or three
times. That's fine. Again, that
is something that can become
too cumbersome. However, within
reason, this is the of the
prophet
says and if he would eat at
anyone at anyone's behest, if
he would honor anyone's
invitation he would not leave
their home, their domicile,
their wherever he was invited
to. Until he would make dua for
that person upon completing
that meal.
[Silence]
Hola.
the home of of
and they ate there to their
fill. The prophet said upon
their meal's conclusion,
Vick Lee reciprocate your
brother or if you will
compensate your brother He
said, and how do we compensate
him? What is considered
compensation for a meal?
a person goes to a man's home
and eats from his dish and
drinks from his drink then a
person is to
and a
person is to make dua for
that person and that is what is
meant by compensation.
[Silence]
and he would not ever feel
he would not ever feel any kind
of way You sit and eat with any
individual. Whether this person
is young or old or this person
is a free man or a slave or
this person was rich or poor.
The prophet would eat with
anyone. He Sallallahu Would
invite anyone And he would also
honour the invitation of
anyone.
Likewise, the prophet commanded
that one eat with his right
hand. He prohibited that a
person eats with his left hand
and he would say, indeed a
Shaitan does eat with his left
hand and he does drink with his
left hand as well.
In the
[Silence]
eat or drink with his left
hand. This is impermissible He
says and that is the correct
opinion. Some opinions of the
scholars is that it is merely
disliked. discouraged but the
correct opinion is that it is
haram. because if we look at
the patterns in the Quran and
then the We never see a pattern
where a Shaitan does something
and it's considered to merely
be discouraged. Anytime we are
informed of something as
Shaitan does in the Quran, in
the sunnah, It articulates that
this is haram. and an
additional portion of
prohibition is that a Shaitan
does it. So, it's haram and
also Shaitan does it. This is
the pattern that we see in the
Quran and in the Sunnah. But
when we do not have anything
clearly saying this is haram.
But we do have the prophet
saying does this. This
articulates what? Prohibition.
According to the patterns of
the Quran and Sunnah. In a way
that Allah speaks, in the way
that the prophet speaks. The
way that the companions
understand this. Right?
Likewise, a group of companions
complained to the prophet that
they do not feel satisfied
after eating. No matter how
much they eat, they do not feel
satisfied.
that the
prophet commanded them
to eat together And to not eat
separately. And that they
mention Allah's name over their
food when they go to eat. That
they say bismillah. Likewise,
another narration